let's go
and why are you all coming to the
world's greatest camp for two weeks
because a secret celebrity
i was actually looking for because we
all love each other and you know
something something wildcats
welcome folks i'm just gonna need to
collect your phones snacks and all
electronic devices it's only for two
weeks but sasha doesn't know that sasha
is your phone
this summer camp shallow lake has been
selected for a very special opportunity
to tell you all about it mr corbin blue
you guys are going to be the first camp
to put on frozen
best summer ever
it's my first camp should we spread out
our bed assignments or do the new girl
cluster my first boyfriend
just hitting me now that you two are
gonna be a thing all summer my first
time really going out for the lead in
the show
it is time to introduce you to your
director
ej caswell
just freaking out a little bit shake
your money maker caswell show me how
[Music]
i cannot focus on anything but auditions
right now what are the two main guys
names and frozen again one is i want to
say gary
none of them are gary you can't just
zephyr on your way through auditions
this time
i promise you
the best is yet to come
scream
what's up wildcats feels like these last
few years have been leading up to
something big
nothing is going to ruin our perfect
summer together
[Music]
one could say the stakes have never been
higher
and one will the stakes have never been
higher
[Music]
you